bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission les
petits bricoleurs aujourd'hui je vais
vous montrer comment réaliser un cahier
tout simple
alors pour cela nous avons besoin de
quelques feuilles de papier a4
d'un morceau d'élastiques que vous
trouverez en mercerie
une compresse que vous trouverez aussi
de votre pharmacie de la colle
au pinceau
deux princes
au crayon à papier une règle
un cutter rappelé hiwar si vous en avez
une paire de ciseaux un stylo
le papier deux camps sont de couleur de
votre choix et les petites chutes de
papier
pour faire une étiquette alors dans un
premier temps nous allons plier les
feuilles de papier a4 en deux
on va payer une par une or bien plié
doit qu'à peu près une vingtaine de
feuilles massa dira
alors d'autres l'appeler sûrs
dont vous mettez en å comme ça on va
prendre les pinces mettra lippens
dessous
et ensuite on va mettre de la colle sur
le dos et on va prendre la compresse
on va mettre dessus pour assembler les
feuilles
alors qu'on va mettre la colle
surtout la partie du dos comme ça
et là on va prendre la compresse on met
dessus
on referme le parti du but comme ça et
puis on peut remettre un petit peu de
colle alors dessus que ça tienne mieux
donc là il faudra bien laisser sécher
moi quand j'ai fait ça j'ai laissé toute
une nuit
ça donne ça une fois bien sécher voilà
ça tient bien les feuilles avant l'étape
suivante pour apprendre le papier canson
pour faire la couverture donc voila moi
je fais comme ça je prends le crayon à
papier je marque la
messa
alors donc je vais prendre la règle
avec le cutter que je vais couper
alors donc je reprends le cahier
quand qu'avec le prix world je marche
bien
je refais
mais avant de coller je regarde bien là
la compresse elle ne dépasse pas un peu
donc je compte bien sur le bord et là je
trouve un petit peu en biais
là aussi je coupe un petit peu envié
alors je vais raccourcir un petit peu
aussi la compresse et là
ça va faire du bien
on va pas oublier de mettre l'élastique
donc on va mettre l'élastique à ce
niveau là
e
bien laisser son doigt dessus un quart
d'heure vingt minutes il ya laissé
sécher
donc on va mettre la colle sur le dos
et puis on va mettre aussi un petit peu
de colle là où il ya la compresse et de
l'autre côté aussi
maintenant on va le mettre où on avait
mis le dour
alors faudra bien laisser sécher aussi
une bonne demi-heure bien laisser sécher
avant de l'ouvrir
on va faire une étiquette pour coller
sur le cahier moi j'ai pris la forme
ovale
d'après vous choisissez votre forme
soiron rectangle comme vous voulez
non alors qu'on va découvrir
voilà l'étiquette qu'on va coller sur le
cahier
alors soit vous écrivez mon cahier vous
écrivez moment j'ai écrit à mon cahier
dessus et
qu'on est là
et ensuite laon si vous voulez laisser
comme ça à vous laisser comme ça moi je
vais l'arrondir un petit peu le ce coin
là donc on arrondit les angles
voilà maintenant votre cahier terminée
voilà avec l'élastique ce que ça donne
des cours
j'espère que ça vous a plu et je vous
dis à bientôt